a master he's a master you know we'd
like to put those labels on things
Mastery is a way of life
Jocelyn would you mind reading a poem
from your new book I know you have many
different chapters and sections in it
but this one is become a master becoming
a master yes I'm going to read you a
little bit before it so it sets up the
poem a bit
you know
actors are always asking me how do I
become a master what is a master you
know so this is a bit of an answer to
that
forget comparing yourself to any master
recognize that what you admire in that
person is simply a reflection of those
qualities already existent in you
keep your eye on that ball therein lies
the synchronicity what you already know
you summoned into your life for you to
know again more profoundly
be grateful for that synchronicity
here's what I tell my students about
becoming a master
start
keep going
you think you're starting to get the
hang of it keep going
you admire someone else's work and go
into doubt how I can't do that keep
going
you feel like maybe possibly you kind of
got the hang of it now you don't keep
going
you ask someone for an opinion
their response is insultingly polite
keep going you fall into doubt to keep
going you fall into depression keep
going you ask someone else's opinion and
their response is favorable you realize
they have no idea what they're talking
about keep going you feel better and
maybe even a little proud of what you
can do now keep going
you chastise yourself for thinking that
keep going you indulge in some form of
self-sabotage for comfort
keep going
self-loathing Creeps in keep going
depression visits again keep going you
are asked
you ask a professional for their opinion
they respond favorably you think you
know better
keep going
you wake up sad keep going loneliness
sets in keep going although you can't
possibly imagine why you become Restless
keep going you receive praise from the
one person you believe matters most it
doesn't matter keep going you just keep
going because there's nothing else you
can do
Mastery arrives and you mistake it for a
gust of wind
keep going
what events had led up to you writing
this poem Oh the poem
well
you know actors are seeking that
it's not Mastery they're seeking they're
seeking like where is the end point
where I know that I am glorious or I've
won the wars or I you know it's that it
is a reach for a satisfaction of ego you
know and they're saying it's a master
you know the master I used to tell a
thing in class about how you know Seven
Samurai is one of my favorite movies and
tashiro mafuni you know with his sword
he's he's sort of a not a very good
Samurai and he has a sword name makes a
Big Show and he's like slashing slashing
clashing with this thing in this wall
and uh he's just silly the master comes
along and he has a sword and he goes
and five flies fall to the ground
so Mastery is really less you are so
confident you can do less and have the
same impact you're so confident you can
do less and have a bigger impact and
what is that less
but a Stillness
do you see how I'm going it's less you
come from a place of Stillness so the
master is really working within that Gap
the whole time and if it's acting you
know he's he's working with less but
he's more entered there's a painter I
talked to on the phone yesterday is is
85 he's a fantastic painter his name is
Julio lores if you want to look up his
beautiful work
and I was talking about the phone
because we've been exchanging gifts
and I found out his daughter lived in
Los Angeles so he said are you going to
come to Los Angeles and visit your
daughter because I want to see him and
he said no Yoshi I go why no because now
I'm painting
and I said oh well you know I have a
place in New York and your son lives in
Brooklyn right yeah
do you go see your son for a visit
I I have too many paintings I can paint
all the paintings that I want to paint
and blew out your microphone I'm sorry
but you know it just knocked me over
that's Mastery he's in it for the
meditation the painting is a meditation
when he's putting paint on a canvas he
is entering he is entering the canvas
he's not in this world he's not worried
he doesn't worry what people think about
him because he's not coming to visit his
daughter in California if she wants to
visit him you come see me I don't want
to get on planes I'm old and I'm
painting same thing with his son so
Mastery is really a state it's not
something to read I'm gonna I have
achieved Mastery no that's a desire for
some super admiration she's a master
he's a master you know we like to put
those labels on things Mastery is a way
of life
what is leaving behind a trail of
breadcrumbs
wow you know the cover of the book
um are these hands and I'm surprised how
many people don't know what those hands
are those hands are from the cave of
hands I can't say it in Spanish or I'd
love to Rattle it off
something but it's called the cave of
hands and it's in Patagonia it's in
Argentina Patagonia and
and those hands are 65 000 years old
they are the first expression of man I
am I was here I matter
you know we had cave paintings and those
were the stories of the hunt and the
first actors or the guys who came back
from the hunt and told the story around
the campfire and those cave paintings of
animals and such are are quite old but
they are storytelling
these hands are this impulse and this
desire to express self
so they knocked me out they really
knocked me out so a trail of breadcrumbs
you know is from the poem that opens the
book about what is an artist and they
leave behind a trail of breadcrumbs
means they leave behind hopefully
inspired work that when we look at the
it's like a little path this is inspired
work when an artist gives you inspired
work you know just like he knew it I say
oh you know it in your heart you know
when they leave that work and you see
that work you know it you know that's
inspired work that same inspiration hits
you when you see the Michelangelo you
burst into tear when you see the David
by Michelangelo you burst into tears
because it's my God that came from man
that's inspired so those are the trail
of breadcrumbs this is the direction
we're going in follow the inspiration to
find out what man is capable of as a
spiritual being